on Sunday U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken and defense secretary Lloyd
Austin traveled from Poland across
Ukraine to the capital key for
face-to-face talks with the country's
president of vladimirs and Lansky that's
the highest level U.S visit since the
start of the Russian invasion Ukraine
has been pressing Western allies for
heavier weapons to fight Russia's
campaign in the East now military aid
has started to flow the U.S diplomats
pledged another 700 million dollars in
military aid and said Washington would
reopen its Embassy in the Ukrainian
capital
a warm welcome back to Kiev after a
secretive train journey across the
Polish Ukraine border to the Capitol
the high-level delegation sent by U.S
President Joe Biden to offer
face-to-face messages of support and
admiration the reason we're back is
because of you uh because of the
extraordinary courage leadership and
success that you've had in pushing back
this horrific Russian aggression both
blinken and defense secretary Lloyd
Austin offered zielinski condolences for
the loss of life in Ukraine and further
economic and Military Support
as ever zielinski was grateful then to
the point about his needs
the priorities are weapons and support
from the United States and our partners
from European leaders
in terms of our army strengths and
support in certain areas
support zielinski was quick to point out
the U.S has already given billions in
assistance since Russia's Invasion and
repeated his military must have
top-level armaments if it is to beat
back the Invader in places like the
donbass region where Russia has tried to
reinvigorate its efforts to achieve
changing goals in Ukraine
its focus no longer Kiev the capital but
the East and southern coast of Ukraine
safely back across the Polish border
after the meeting Austin said Ukraine
can be victorious over Russia
um in terms of uh our their ability to
win the first step in winning is
believing that you can win and so they
believe that we can win we believe that
we can win they can win if they have the
right uh equipment the right support and
we're going to do everything we can
continue to do everything we can to
ensure that that gets you Austin and
blinken together announced a further 700
million dollars in Military Support for
the Ukraine cause before Austin moved on
to Ramstein Germany for a meeting with
NATO defense ministers
let's take a closer look at this with
the Joshua schifferinson who's an
associate professor of international
relations at Boston University he's an
expert in U.S foreign policy and the
history of the Cold War welcome to DW
let's start with General Austin there um
some people would listen to what he said
and wonder if he's being overly
optimistic talking about Ukraine being
able to win this war and I'll tell you
why I asked because whichever way the
cards fall the post-conflict decades are
likely to be filled with massive
insecurity for whoever thinks they've
come out on top
yes I think that's doubly right in fact
number one I think secretary Austin
might be a little uh over enthusiastic
and estimating Ukraine's ability to push
Russia back out of the donbass and the
Southern Coastline and then number two
as you were alluding to we are facing A
Renewed period of insecurity in Europe
likes of which we haven't seen in over
three decades and so the notion of
Ukraine winning against Russia right now
that's a short-term Victory the question
of what happens after this uh remains
highly uncertain
and so we have secretary blinken and
general Austin arriving in Ukraine with
Joe Biden's good wishes and a
multi-million dollar checkbook for
Ukraine to have pretty much anything it
wants except a no-fly zone it's
President Biden right to draw the line
there
yes he's in my opinion he is entirely
right to join the line there uh right
now the U.S is arming Ukraine it is uh
preparing Ukraine to resist and push
back against Russian aggression but a
new flood zone would mean that the U.S
and presumably the other NATO allies are
actually fighting Russia over Ukraine
that could very well lead to the World
War III scenario that President Biden
alluded to in various speakers and which
we should all be highly concerned about
okay we're going to hear from the U.S
defense secretary and then come back to
you
uh we want to see Russia uh weakened to
the degree that it can't do the kinds of
things that it has done in invading
Ukraine so it has already lost a lot of
military capability and a lot of a lot
of its troops quite frankly and uh we
want to see them not have the capability
to very quickly reproduce that
capability
so Joshua shiffrinson that's General
Austin there it sounds like he's really
asking Ukraine to try and make up for
the United States underestimating
Vladimir Putin's ambition all these
years
well so I I think that could be part of
it and certainly the US has been arming
Ukraine quite heavily providing
significant economic and Military
diplomatic assistance since the War
Began and I agree with you that part of
this is a Maya culpa campaign for
underestimating the Russian threat for a
while but there's another element there
which I think goes to a point you raised
a few minutes ago which is if we think
that Russia is going to be a challenge
for the foreseeable future any stuff
that we can take now that would weaken
Putin over the long term we can Russia
over the longer term rebalance the
Western Advantage so this is the first
cell this is the opening Salvo and I
think a longer term competition that is
also future oriented as much backwardly
oriented yeah this is going to go in all
sorts of directions because how much is
this water sort of wake-up call then for
U.S uh foreign policy and once we're out
of this mess how is the U.S foreign
policy likely to to sort of pivot and
change
well so I I actually think that U.S
foreign policy right now is very much
focused on the Russia threat but over
time we're going to see the U.S
continuing to Pivot towards China even
uh deputy secretary of defense Kathleen
Hicks today gave a speech that alluded
to the U.S continuing focus upon China
but what I think we're going to see
going forward is a renewed nato-wide
effort to focus on Russia with the U.S
providing diplomatic the Strategic
leadership but increasing contributions
from many European members of NATO so
this is going to be a continued focal
point even if it isn't the main focus of
American resources okay the next
question in two parts if I may let's
imagine Russia wins this war however
massively
where would that then leave it in the
world a member of the U.N security
Council but probably still under
International sanctions with countries
still desperate to buy its gas despite
their reservations
yes I I think the only thing uh I I
think it is quite worrisome what a
Russian Victory means in this context
not just because uh defeating Ukraine
would be uh an affront the International
Community would not just be problematic
for Russia but that Russia's isolation
is going to be quite profound in a
political sense even if it is
economically still intertwined with the
world this is a recipe for disaster
we're talking about there a country that
has massive economic resources a
lucrative commodity in its oil and gas
exports and yet is on the out many
members of the International Community
this is a recipe for long-term
instability
um that Russian Victory is in some ways
almost worse than a Russian defeat where
as bad as a Russian defeat and we we
have this at the sort of the the end of
a sort of as of a a trail of Russian
movement over the last 10 years where
it's driven to put itself at the center
of world affairs displacing the us as
the key player in Syria for example and
increasing of Vladimir Putin's in the
Middle East but Russia's incompetence in
this war does seem to have undermined
that image somewhat
yes so I I think I would frame Russia's
goals a little differently Russia has
been somebody's following International
crisis and trying to preserve its
lingering influence in the world and as
you alluded to it's an incredibly clumsy
ham-handed almost self-harming uh in the
process of doing so and coming out of
this Russia has essentially encircled
itself with NATO never more unified
countries like China and India
distancing themselves in some way from
Moscow this is a situation where Russia
is going to be a pariah State and I
think Putin has badly miscalculated
okay so whichever way this goes the
world is going to be a much more
dangerous and unstable place for the
next decade or so
oh yes I I think for more than next
decade I think if the US and Russia
don't uh take good steps now don't take
wise steps to sustain some degree of
diplomacy we can imagine a long-term
break a real deep break between the west
and Russia that would simply encourage
Russia to behave ever more irresponsibly
in Europe and encourage the European
countries in the US as well to really uh
further deepen moscow's isolation and
set the stage for continuing insecurity
tensions and crises the likes which we
haven't seen since the 1950s and the
1960s not sure how well I'm going to
sleep tonight but thank you for that
analysis Joshua shiffrinson from Boston
University
thank you
on the Diplomatic front Russia's foreign
Ministry took aim at Germany today
declaring 40 diplomatic staff persona
non grata and ordering their expulsion
that's about a third of Germany's
Diplomatic Corps in Russia Moscow said
the decision was in retaliation for
Germany's expulsion of 40 Russian
diplomats earlier this month German
foreign Ministry set the Tit for Tat
measure was expected but in no way
Justified
well despite its actions against Moscow
and its support for Kiev Germany is
under pressure over its apparent
slowness in supplying weapons to Ukraine
Berlin stance has been particularly
criticized by Baltic states like Estonia
DW's Chief political editor Michaela
kufner discussed Germany's position with
the Estonian prime minister akaya kalas
prime minister kallus you say You're
Expecting strong leadership from Germany
right now what exactly do you mean what
we definitely expect is that Germany is
is also I mean supporting all the
decisions that we make together and also
showing the leadership in democracy of
course you know gas or an oil could be
expensive but but freedom is really
Priceless so if you if you
take the leadership role and also
explain what is at stake here you know
our neighbors problems today are hard
problems tomorrow if we help to end this
war you know there will be less war
refugees for uh Germany there will be
less
problems regarding economy as well and
therefore uh you know these strong
sanctions
hitting hitting hard
would would be something that would
maybe end this end this war not
immediately but still so this is one
side and the other side where we expect
Germany's leadership is is in NATO uh
you know I've very carefully followed
the discussions that you have in Germany
and I understand what is the starting
point here but if if you say that we
don't want to go to any other war that
is going on somewhere else I totally
understand that but if NATO is a
defensive Alliance we are in this
together
also Germany has said Article 5 is is
Ironclad and and Germany will come to
help if if necessary but then it's also
for everybody
important including Germany to make
those decisions so that we make NATO
stronger and there will be no need to
come to any help at all so what do you
feel isn't understood in Berlin yet that
is understood in the Baltic countries
for instance that our neighbor's
problems today are our problems tomorrow
if we don't help our neighbors when
their house is on fire the fire will
also catch you know your house prime
minister khalas thank you very much